[Applause]
do you hear that do you know what that
is silence the sound of silence Simon
and Garfunkel wrote a song about it but
silence is a pretty rare commodity these
days and we're all paying a price for it
in terms of our health a surprisingly
big prize as it turns out luckily there
are things we can do right now both
individually and as a society to better
protect our health they give us more of
the benefits of the Sounds of Silence I
assume that most of you know that too
much noise is bad for your hearing
whenever you leave a concert or a bar
and you have that ringing in your ears
you can be certain that you have done
some damage to your hearing likely
permanent and that's very important
however noise affects our health in many
different ways beyond hearing they are
less well known but they are just as
dangerous as the auditory effects so
what do we mean when we talk about noise
well noise is defined as unwanted sound
and as such both has a physical
component the sound and of psychological
component the circumstances that make
the sound unwanted a very good example
is a rock concert a person attending the
rock concert being exposed to 100
decibels does not think of the music as
noise this person likes the band and
even paid $100 for the ticket so no
matter how loud the music this person
doesn't think of it of noise in contrast
think of a person living 3 blocks away
from the concert hall that person is
trying to read a book but cannot
concentrate because of the music and
although the sound pressure levels are
much lower in this situation this person
still thinks of the music as noise
and it made sugar reactions that can in
the long run have health consequences so
why are quiet space is so important
because noise affects our health in so
many ways beyond hearing however it's
becoming increasingly difficult to find
quiet spaces in times with constantly
increasing traffic growing urbanization
construction sites air conditioning
units leaf blowers lawn mowers outdoor
concerts and bars personal music players
and your neighbors partying until 3:00
a.m. in 2011 the World Health
Organization estimated that 1.6 million
healthy life years are lost every year
due to exposure to environmental noise
in the Western European Member States
alone one important effect of noises
that disturbs communication you may have
to raise your voice to be understood in
extreme cases you may even have to pause
the conversation it's also more likely
to be misunderstood in a noisy
environment and these are all likely
reasons why studies have found the
children who attend schools and noisy
areas are more likely to lag behind
their peers in academic performance
another very important health effect of
noise is the increased risk for
cardiovascular disease and those who are
exposed to relevant noise levels for
prolonged periods of time noises stress
especially if we have little or no
control over it
our body excretes stress hormones like
adrenaline and cortisol that lead to
changes in the composition of our blood
and in the structure of our blood
vessels which have been shown to be
stiffer after a single night of noise
exposure epidemiological studies show
associations between the noise exposure
and an increased risk for high blood
pressure heart attacks and stroke and
although the overall risk increases are
relatively small this still constitutes
a major public health problem because
noise is so ubiquitous and so many
people are exposed to relevant noise
a recent study found that US society
could save 3.9 billion dollars each year
by lowering environmental noise exposure
by five decibels just by saving costs
for treating cardiovascular disease the
other diseases like cancer diabetes and
obesity that have been linked to noise
exposure but we do not have enough
evidence yet to in fact conclude that
these diseases are caused by the noise
yet another important effect of noise is
sleep disturbance sleep is a very active
mechanism that recuperates us and
prepares us for the next wake period a
quiet bedroom is a cornerstone of what
sleep researchers call a good sleep
hygiene and our auditory system has a
watchman function it's constantly
monitoring our environment for threats
even while we're sleeping so noise in
the bedroom can cause an a delay in the
time it takes us to fall asleep it can
wake us up during the night and it can
prevent our blood pressure from going
down during the night we have the
hypothesis that if these noise in your
sleep disturbances continue for months
and years that an increased risk for
cardiovascular disease is likely the
consequence however we are often not
aware of these noise induced sleep
disturbances because we're unconscious
while we're sleeping in the past we've
done Studies on the effects of traffic
noise on sleep and research subjects
would often wake up in the morning and
say I had a wonderful night I fell
asleep right away never really woke up
when we would then go back to the
physiological signals we had recorded
during the night we would often see
numerous awakenings and a severely
fragmented sleep structure these
awakenings were too brief - for the
subjects to regain consciousness and to
remember them during the next morning
but they may never nevertheless have a
profound impact on how restful our sleep
is so when is loud too loud a good sign
of too loud is once you start changing
your behavior you may have to raise your
voice to be understood or you increase
the volume of
TV you're avoiding outside areas or
you're closing your window you're moving
your bedroom to the basement of the
house or you even have sound insulation
installed many people will move away to
less noisy areas but obviously not
everybody can afford that so what can we
do right now to improve our sound
environment and to better protect our
health well first of all if something's
too loud
speak up for example many owners of
movie theaters seem to think that only
people hard-of-hearing are still going
to the to the movies if you complain
about the noise and nothing happens
demand a refund and leave that's the
language that managers typically do
understand also talk to your children
about the health effects of noise and
that listening to loud music today will
have consequences when they're older you
can also move your bedroom to the quiet
side of the house where your own
building shields you from road traffic
noise if you're looking to rent or buy a
new place make low noise a priority
visit the property during different
times of the day and talk to the
neighbors about noise you can wear
noise-cancelling headphones when you're
traveling or if your office has high
background noise levels in general seek
out quiet spaces especially on the
weekend or when you're on vacation allow
your system to wind down I very
appropriately for this talk attended a
noise conference in Japan four years ago
when I returned to the United States and
entered the airport the wall of sound
hit me this tells you that we don't
realize anymore the constant degree of
noise pollution we're exposed to and how
much we could profit from more quiet
spaces what else can we do about noise
well very much like a carbon footprint
we all have a noise footprint and there
are things we can do to make that noise
footprint smaller for example don't
start mowing your lawn at 7 a.m. on a
Saturday morning your neighbors will
thank you or use a rake instead of a
leaf blower in general noise reduction
at the
makes the most sense so whenever you're
looking to buy a new car air
conditioning unit blender you name it
make low noise a priority many
manufacturers will list the noise levels
the devices generate and some even
advertise with them use that information
many people think that stronger noise
regulation and enforcement are good
ideas even obvious solutions perhaps but
it's not as easy as you may think
because many of the activities that
generate noise also generate revenue
think about an airport and all that the
business that is associated with it our
research tells politicians at what noise
level they can expect a certain health
effect and that helps inform better
noise policy Robert Koch supposedly once
said one day mankind will fight noise as
relentlessly as cholera in the pest I
think we're there and I hope that we
will win this fight and when we do we
can all have a nice quiet celebration
thank you
[Applause]